foreign
there's a new Fast and Furious movie in
theater so we hit the streets in Vegas
to ask folks what's your favorite word
associated with Fast and Furious it
probably starts with an F
uck I love Fast and Furious I'm so
stoked to see that one yes I am
absolutely
okay you seem really pumped I love Fast
and Furious what is it about the Fast
and Furious franchise that just gets
your motor run the men
you got a lot of action they do a lot of
stunts that you know most people don't
do I hope this is the last one honestly
I really do it's getting too way out
there never really been my speed huh did
you do that on purpose yeah I was a pun
right there slip that in for the camera
are there no new ideas would really be
my question like is this number 14 maybe
going to space they fighting dudes with
Transformer bikes it just doesn't make
sense anymore I just want them to you
know bring it back to the original
bringing it back to the street racing
can't beat the first one the first one
you could actually believe it I remember
all my uncles when they watched it in
theaters they left the parking lot
drifting in their trucks after watching
it it was good stuff I just don't know
what Innovative things they can still
bring into the series we went to outer
space the last movie where do you go
from here Mars fast 10 in Vegas now this
would be crazy what if they got the dock
from Back to the Future and he gonna
come with the DeLorean and somehow Dom
gets it and he has to go back to the
past I feel like they could go back to
the past and save old bro but that's
just future thinking
[Music]
of course The Rock he had a swept in
there and just kind of took over all of
it Tyrese Tyrese that's my man Roman is
also kind of funny but he's kind of
super funny
I know a little something about being
stupid funny
Tyrese does a great job of acting
you got Ludacris in there you got
Michelle Rodriguez what it is that she
likes to have recently wait wait okay
let's bury the fast 10 talk just for a
sec you all just met tonight we just met
so we haven't met that boundary yet like
what I'm sorry you like Tyrese and all
of them yes okay he's a great singer and
actor Never Gonna never get to you again
it'd definitely be the first one the
first one easily past five Too Fast Too
Furious so personally that's where they
lost me at that's where I lost you
there's like eight movies since then
yeah I like the other ones but they just
not like they use the Beast you gotta
say fast seven the weight behind the
movie and everything surrounding it was
just amazing and I think they did it
pretty well just it's the original one
you know like that's pretty much like
every movie if you ask me like the very
first one's always the best one yeah I
don't even know which one is which but I
love your favorite uh the one uh oh gosh
it was you know the one with the cars
and they go really fast
I couldn't even tell you the difference
between all of them I don't think there
is one it's just one long continuous
movie but that's sort of the fun
awesome crazy crazy amazing room baby
room vroom is a great gangster
legendaries actually pass I don't know
fast fast fast fast top tier fantastic
that's actually three words but it
sounded good though nobody wants to say
family it's it what the guy says it was
right your gallery of fans was all
thinking family oh family yeah oh he
says we're family family
[Music]
speaking of family good luck to my new
favorite family right here
you'll never be able to break my family
what we learn in this edition of on the
street well everyone seems to have a
different word to summarize Fast and
Furious and almost nobody said family
better luck next time Dom thanks for
checking out on the street I'm Mark
Ellis and we'll see you next time right
here at Rotten Tomatoes after you see
the movie make sure you rate and review
at rottentomatoes.com
no you look fantastic if anybody from
the Bellagio is watching why don't you
make your fountain into a pool
unfortunately that's my bad son no I'm
good no no no no no no no I got you yeah